this is a production of Cornell
University
so thanks for the opportunity this is
not going to be your typical scientific
seminar I'm going to cover the basics of
climate change bear with me I'm an
entomologist I'm not a climate scientist
but I've also dedicated off at a time of
learning the science of climate change
I'm going to cover the basics never all
going out to dinner get your credit card
out because we're going to have an
expensive meal but the point is what's
changing on the menu and then my talk
about what Cornell is doing a little bit
from the academic side which are all
part of but also facilities and
operations there really is a lot going
on it would just launched a report from
the senior leadership sustainability
group on a set of recommendations to get
us to carbon neutrality by 2035 someone
summarized that Tony failed to mention
that this our latest publication we
actually published together made the
front cover of weed science my picture
no what's that it no okay well whatever
okay so Tony and provide a little bio
but I'm going to add a few more things
here i am milking a cow and costa rica
few years ago with one thing you never
forget and that's like riding a bike you
never forget how to milk a cow and the
tour guide was just blown away that I
could milk a cow and I did it rather
effectively I also got really excited
about this anaerobic digester back there
and he said we never had a tourist who
could milk a cow got it excited about
the manure I grew up on a little farm in
Wisconsin had a pet crow nadinekarl
although recently I realized it may have
been Carla but you know when you're nine
years old you don't have that kind of
conversation with your pets spend time
in Marine Corps Vietnam veteran I tell
this story because it helps with a lot
of different audiences I'm not just a
professor are going to talk to this
group a part of it I've also held
leadership roles at Cornell and when
you're in one of those roles you're
supposed to see the big picture you
can't just be an entomologist anymore
I'm also a parent climate change
as personal effect my daughters and
lastly the Homeland Security motto is if
you see something say something I'm here
to say something ok how many Trekkies
probably how they get their food
replicators right so what happens with a
blue both their engines are out that
what was the guy the Klingons you know
they're incapacitated they're lost out
in space in trouble they had to be
self-sufficient that looks like the same
place our situation we don't have a
whole lot of places to go got to take
care of what we have and I think it's
better to tell the truth make a little
uncomfortable so here we go all right
this is the Endeavour first time I saw
this what a remarkable selfie but that
orange band is the troposphere right
here about this part of the world's
maybe 56 miles high that's where the
action occurs that's where eighty
percent of the climate change activity
occurs it's like a very very thin
blanket solar radiation comes down hits
the surface of the earth if it's white
snow most of that energy is reflected
back if it comes down hits a dark
surface it's absorbed that some of that
energy is then irradiated in s IR and I
just learned this deal that they
listening to Toby alt if you had a
candle in your hand and you feel the
warmth is it the actual air that's
warming up it's not it's the radiant
energy so it's that same kind of energy
reflecting off the surface of the planet
its carbon of greenhouse gases which are
essential to life on the planet and some
of those are reflected back so we're
simply adding more and more greenhouse
gases to that thin little layer that
blanket is getting thicker it is getting
warmer
one of the carbon diox-- one of the
greenhouse gases carbon dioxide on the
bottom is year one thousand year 2000
you can see the Industrial Revolution
how quickly things have changed when we
started burning fossil fuels fossil fuel
we should be at about 270 parts per
million we're now at 404 more or less
forty percent above normal if we keep
going business as usual would hit nine
hundred parts per million that means
we'll have 60 days here in this part of
the world above 90 degrees in the summer
time very different nothing new Tyndall
hand others had this worked out in 1800s
what a greenhouse gas is all about one
of the things that I've had farmers say
to me is when I mentioned this carbon 12
is actually increasing the atmosphere
and it comes from the burning of an
ancient plants or fossil fuels it's
another direct indicator that the
burning of fossil fuels is changing the
atmosphere and I think this is 97 out of
100 scientists agree we are the cause
climate changes happening I think it's
now 99 out of 100 pretty solid evidence
another way to look at this is the
atmosphere is a bathtub we're filling it
up with greenhouse gases the natural
systems which would be the drain the
oceans plants etc to absorb the
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere can
no longer keep up we're putting more
water in or greenhouse gases the drain
has not changed the bathtub is filling
up the relationship between carbon
dioxide and temperature going back
400,000 years we all know where these
data come from ice cores the bubbles in
ice and if you look at the top you can
see how co2 fluctuates over the years
from 400,000 years at current time and
so does the temperature very much
aligned co2 decreases temperature
decreases co2 increases temperature
increases and of course here we are in
current times going off the chart
where's it come from transportation
about a third electricity production any
idea how many cars are produced per day
on the planet I just forgot okay I'll
make something up i think it's like
180,000 a date here we go how many
flights commercial flights a day 93,000
these are things we take you know we
enjoy there's my 93 Volvo up there I
still drive that I Drive so electricity
industry but agriculture in the u.s.
contributes about ten percent of
greenhouse gases worldwide it's more
like eighteen to twenty percent so it's
not always fair to point once fingered
agriculture as a major yes it's a
contributor but there's a lot of other
sources of these greenhouse gases so
let's just summarize we've gained about
one and a half degrees globally it's
warming twice as fast at the poles the
iditarod the dogsled race every year now
they're concerned they're leavin habit
they keep moving further north 2001-2010
hot x decade 15 hottest year this year
will surpass all previous year's hotter
summers warmer winters nights are
warming faster than days the rate of
warming is very fast we're going to gain
as much heat in the next hundred years
as we have since the last ice age and
again you can't turn this off even if we
stop and really behave today it'll take
hundreds if not thousands of years to
pretty cool a break and the distinction
between climate and weather weather is
what's happening outside today over
short term climate decades in length so
we face a challenge a grand challenge
the evidence with a few exceptions when
i did my TEDx talk we look for great
pictures of glaciers and we had this
beautiful one I thought let me check and
was actually highlighted because it was
one of the few glaciers that's actually
growing we didn't use that picture
glaciers are melting worldwide this is
an important source of irrigation water
and chili and a lot of other countries
if you haven't been to Glacier National
Park I suggest you get there soon
because the glaciers will be gone in
about 20 years I'm talking to my
daughter's about where they want to go
next year and they want to go to Glacier
Park while the glaciers are still there
this is summer sea ice the Arctic this
is a actually I look just today at where
we are with retreating sea ice in the
summertime it rapidly freezes over and
is rapidly freezing right now but this
is an image of in September and you can
see it's about 700,000 square miles less
than it should be when you compared to
historical records so here's an example
of where solar radiation comes in it's
absorbed by that deep blue ocean warms
of water melts more ice you get it
there's actually a concern as the
passage is open here because it will
well one there's a military concern
because of more Russian and Chinese
transport but also invasive species that
exist in bilges and ships because the
ships are going to get from point A to
point B much faster there's a likelihood
of more of those kind of invasives being
moved around the planet
oceans are changing thirty percent more
acidic than there should be the rising
thermal expansion accounts for about a
third of that much more comes from
melting glaciers glaciers obviously I
think most everyone is aware of the
acidification is affecting shell forming
organisms how many have hugged a redwood
kind of hard not to write these are
these the largest creatures on earth
living no okay well are big they're
massive and are hard not to hug so in
the Sierras invasive species and other
plants are moving up the Sierras because
of warming conditions so someone asks a
question what about the redwoods well it
turns out there's just this narrow band
of perfect soil conditions for the
redwoods so in time they're already
under stress but in time they will be
compromised by warming temperatures even
these brand creatures so let's talk
about agriculture and food security with
all these changes it's no longer
business as usual there's more
variability more risk the impacts or
local local to global food production is
moving north we've essentially shifted
close to one planting zone North this
obviously has impact for farmers in
Manitoba where they expanded grain
production growing seasons are longer we
gained about 10 days here natwest it's
more 19 the Northwest 16 days but that
doesn't necessarily mean additional
growing days for farmers because of more
extreme weather we're having wet spells
in the spring or in the fall and
interferes with harvest or planting some
of our farmers have heard a wolf
mentioned this a while back where
they're splitting their planting they
get in early while they have a dry
period early spring with a long season
corn then they'll wait for this sort of
the wet spell and then they'll come in
with a short season porn later on so
they still get a crop and we're having
more heavy precipitation events
especially in the northeast or up 71
percent
there was a Libby pumpkin which grows
ninety percent of their excuse me bros
almost all their pumpkins within 90
miles of their processing facility in
Illinois in 2012 they had a very wet
spring in 2014 a very wet fall which
meant planting or harvesting the
pumpkins was compromised i think in 2012
they had about half the crop you
normally would and they produce almost
all the pumpkin pie pie filling in the
US this is serious we're talking about
pumpkin pie filling but it's an example
of diversification spread out your wrist
don't plan all your pumpkins close to
the plant this is a quote from a farmer
we've done some videos of farmers
interviewing them their perceptions of
climate change and it just happened to
go to this this farm right after a heavy
downpour and he had lost eighty thousand
dollars with so self alpha C do you just
planted it but the heavy rain everything
was washed away as a farmer you can
weather the storm but you can't weather
continuous storms and Yan 2014 they had
five inches of rain in four hours I
slipped on the Long Island had 18 inches
in 24 hours these more of these events
are occurring and this is where I really
get into the climate change for job
security say they're more insects excuse
me the likelihood of with longer seasons
more generations new invasive coming in
the bottom the corn earworm down here
what is a pest primarily of sweet corn
historically when I started that Cornell
it was a late season corn that's late
season pests now cheer year-round
presumably because now it can overwinter
last week there was a forum in
Washington DC on climate and pests and I
heard Lou Ziska a weed scientist talk
about some of his work it was just
amazing
he found he had a call from someone in
the ARS lab and say we got this old seed
that's like 60 years old should we throw
it away and he is sure many went women
let's see those plants grew under much
lower co2 levels than what we have today
and he did some comparisons are clearly
the weeds have evolved but he summarized
hit talk like this preliminary suggest
that we impose greater limitations on
crop production and earlier assumed the
worst weeds often wild relatives of crop
may be able to better adapt to increase
co2 temperature associate with the
future changes at the same time
adaptation when wild weed lines may
serve as a means to enhance adaptation
of cultivated lines special especially
Surya lines to increase production as
co2 increases so we're going to both the
fighting weeds but also learning from
them and there were several other
stories at this forum crop diseases and
even insects they're just some of these
subtle but kind of scary changes that
are occurring this is an interesting
prediction looking forward the gray band
is historical high and low average
temperature by year from roughly
eighteen fifty to current times and
here's projections the red line would be
business as usual worst-case scenario
and what it shows is by 2050 the coldest
year we will experience will be above
any high temperature we've ever previous
150 years we're moving there such
temperature band
and here we go watch carefully this is
average temperatures from the 1800 to
2100 this is going to show increasing
temperatures over the next 150 years now
we're not supposed to go by 2 degrees C
that will happen at roughly 20 28 and by
the end of the century we're past five
degrees C want to see that again no I
have told 12 o'clock no one ok all right
we'll go through this one more time
ok
that's looking forward in temperature
let's look forward in precipitation
patterns just find new york on the map
and you'll see it's darker blue and
thatched that means we'll have generally
increase in overall precipitation annual
precipitation in the winter and spring
fall so so summers a little drier but
then look at the southwest it's going to
get drier and drier and drier does that
mean that we here in the Northeast have
an opportunity to actually diversify and
expand agriculture because we will have
water in the coming years if anybody
follows Toby alts work there's two
papers one in 2015 and one in 2016 this
is the risk of a mega droughts a mega
droughts is 35 years in length or
greater the to the arrows point to mega
droughts were civilizations collapsed
ins in the southwest back in 11-50 in
about 1300 because of long term droughts
but the odds of us having a mega
droughts went from the first paper to
eighty percent to ninety-nine percent in
the southwest that has a extraordinary
impact on agriculture in California
agriculture in Mexico and this
communities there in cities as well
and you know if you can make a dollar on
something why not there's a beer called
global warmer it's actually a very good
beer it's seasonal I have no idea why
it's seasonal I can't always get it but
the little on the back it said extended
refrigeration at retail magnifies beers
carbon footprint please enjoy as soon as
possible comes in a four pack okay let's
go out to dinner so a growing food is
changing supply chains are changing
price volatility is increasing and I had
the opportunity three four years ago to
actually meet with the presidents of
crafts food at that time she's a Cornell
alum and I brought up climate change and
she paused and said price volatility is
costing us about three billion dollars a
year we're a big company but that's a
lot of money so this is a business issue
as well we got to start with the right
ingredients for a good meal agava grown
in northern Mexico and it's been subject
to the drought it's a 10-year crop it's
under severe pressure we're messing with
tequila cork trees around the
Mediterranean with higher temperatures
the bark is changing and they make like
a billion corks a year it's a big deal
but if you drink really good stuff that
where the cork is important because
there's a breathability issue that's
changing so your product will be
different and they're considering there
are synthetic corks etc but the cork
trees are changing which is having an
impact on this these kind of beverages
olives some are grown in California but
the point there is California starting
to lose its winter chill which is
essential for fruit and many nut crops
and at a longer-term UCS did a report
and I think they're guys that are going
to lose about forty percent of their
winter chill by the middle of the
century that's going to affect plums
peaches pears apricots grapes you name
it in the longer term that's a kind of a
hominis change or subtle change in the
background that's a lot of people don't
fully appreciate
if you are producing whiskey in Kentucky
the angel is getting a bigger share
there's evaporation through the oak
barrels the oak oak barrels are stored
essentially out of doors in there's a
firm their buildings but they're open to
the outside so as temperatures increase
there's more evaporation and more loss
of alcohol through the oak and it's
actually enough that they're getting a
little worried and they call that the
angel share at least the angels are
happy okay salad avocado production in
California will be off about forty
percent 30 years because of increasing
temperatures it's hard to grow organic
tomatoes in this part of the world now
because of these early heavy downpours
and the risk of late blight so they have
to be grown under plastic if you're
going to grow lettuce in Salinas Valley
in the future you'll probably need to
switch to more heat tolerant varieties
why is affected because grapes are very
sensitive to temperature changes so
that's going to affect California grapes
and maybe be an advantage for us grain
production worldwide is off a little
because of more extreme in weather
lobsters off the coast of Maine they've
moved north 50 miles the oceans off the
coast of Maine are warming eight times
faster than most any other place on the
planet it's also affected the shrimp
industry which is pretty much crashed if
there were saffron in this rice most
saffron has grown in Iran but about ten
to fifteen percent is from Kashmir in
India because of changes in
precipitation patterns and temperatures
they're going out of business and it's
affecting thousands of farmers in that
part of the world and I though I don't
even want to talk about this one but yes
coffee happened to be in kereka as I
mentioned a few years ago and walk
through some coffee plantations and
yelled it's getting warmer and warmer so
they simply move up the side of the
mountains a little further but obviously
they're going to run out of space
cough there's a coffee bar spreading
worldwide in part related to climate
change that's also impacting industry
vanilla grown on coastal Madagascar is
moving inland because of more storms
increased transportation costs cocoa
probably moved from western Africa to
Central and South America so the point
is if you go to next time you go to a
restaurant just look at the all that's
available to us and changes occurring
but what if you're in a country or
agricultural rain-fed and you really
have limited resources so this we face a
food security challenge globally so
national security challenge the moral
challenge their arguments that the war
in Syria started because of a long-term
drought started driven by climate change
and actually a few years ago there was a
conference on campus Chris Barrett let
it this was not the one that really big
one last year but about four or five
years ago was actually funded by the CIA
they do that and they published there in
the background but I was part of that
sort of background dialogue which was
kind of interesting so I was at the
honor privilege of being in Vietnam in
March and here's a country the make on
17 million people living five feet above
sea level they're really affected by
saltwater intrusion some other
complications but it's a land and a
people on water which is just remarkable
to watch but you can also envision what
would happen what will happen with sea
level rise and they have also 2,000
miles of coastline it's a beautiful
country if anybody gets a chance to go
there just remarkable and wonderful
people and just for the record we're
actually planning to take students there
in January and one of the
internationalizing Cornell curriculum
programs to spend two weeks in the make
on food securities in the news-press fix
us up sharp swings in ingredient prices
we're aware of so on so there's this
concern in the food industry
and another example of a potential
conflict with rising waters in
Bangladesh and changing temperatures in
india movement of people in multiple
countries with nuclear weapons and some
moral issue I'm sure you heard the Pope
came out in support of getting her act
together they've been religious summits
the Dalai Lama harsh Desmond Tutu etc
all right we take a breath and get
pretty depressed overwhelmed by all of
this so I guess we could move wicked nor
deny we're all too busy it's actually in
part not in our DNA we're not responsive
to threats that are far in the future or
somewhere else or more of the immediate
we respond to immediate threats and
general life is good and we're busy
leave me alone so the call to action and
if it's a short book written by Mary
Piper's called the green hope she lays
out and it's her personal story on how
she has one person made a change related
to climate change was actually related
to energy become aware listen to the
science accept it this is the old chute
moment or otherwise and then act and I
love this quote from Zorba the Greek to
live is to roll up your sleeves in a
brace trouble I think we've got
something to put our arms around right
here at Cornell so I'm going to talk
about some of the things going on here
at Cornell both on the sort of the
academic side but also the operations
facility side I think you're all aware
this is a land grant but in particular
we have incredible strength and climate
change in agriculture we have much
capacity beyond that but we have
particular strengths that the nexus of
climate change and agriculture
and I made a list of some of the things
going on and there's many more strengths
and plant breeding soil health nutrient
management hot kyle's give less milk I
sometimes show a picture of some
research out of UC Davis and it shows a
picture of a dairy Kyle on a platform
and there's a shower the cow is getting
a shower the idea was a cow comes in
gets shower cools off and leaves trouble
as the cows didn't leave they just
stayed there so they had to put a little
kicking device to get cows to move on we
have exceptional talent in
communications and climate change water
management ipm etc we have the Northeast
climate Center it's a collaborative
environment it's the right place to take
on this challenge we have the Atkinson
Center innovative research they have a
climate forum making connection through
topical lunches some new initiatives the
US climate change hubs created in 2014
there's actually a sub-sub hub on campus
at the ARS facility but their their
agenda is to bring all parties together
land grants extension stakeholders non
for NGOs etc and coordinate their
efforts there's also the relatively new
cornelis Institute for climate smart
solutions which focuses primarily on
agriculture right now the climate smart
farming program this is an example of
what happening the climate smart Farm
extension team this is the first in the
country where six of our educators
actually have part of the
responsibilities to work on climate
change they are distributed around the
state they have different
responsibilities most are with regional
teams and the other thing being
developed by the Institute are tools
there's a growing degree day tool we
don't do it these are the faculty and
programmers etc we help facilitate this
there's a freeze risk tool and somewhat
relevant to this route for this last
year is also an irrigation scheduler
that looks out 30 days and gives
probability about
plant stress given different scenarios
and you can put in soil type you can put
in crop type you can put in location and
we'll give it for your particular this
kind of prediction for your particular
farm or location so Cornell walking the
walk I'm not sure how many follow this
but we are now committed to carbon
neutrality by 2035 that's a really big
deal it's a really big challenge we have
a corner climate action plan that's been
around for several years that has
something like 60 recommendations to
help us get to a lower carbon footprint
two years ago there was an acceleration
working groups and how do we speed that
all up i co-chaired that more recently
there's a senior leadership campus
committee that just released their
report a couple weeks ago on how to get
us to carbon neutrality as mentioned
early on there's also the president
sustainable campus committee they have
responsibility for implementation of a
lot of these recommendations and as an
institution for a living laboratory
faculty and staff can work on these
issues together and it's a big place
21,000 students 1600 faculty 8,000 staff
600 buildings two thousand acres of land
25,000 light switches annual
here's this summarizes the greenhouse
gas emissions this is basically 2008 to
2014 in 2010 we went from coal by Jim
Hall planner for that so this shows the
combustion emissions obviously dropped
in 2010 when we got off Cole we have to
buy electricity but we're buying less
after 2010 because now we produce a lot
of it commuting is a big deal lot of
travel believe it or not sports teams do
a lot of travel air travel and then some
of this is offset a little bit by for
sequestration and the fact that we're
also selling on occasion electricity and
this shows the net emissions essentially
a thirty percent decrease over that time
span and at the same time an energy
conservation initiative Health Campus
actually grew by about twenty percent
unusually cold winter in 2014 thank you
okay I'm innocent bear with me what time
so ten minutes okay alright I'll just
summarize rather quickly what has been
done I think you're familiar with lakes
or schooling this is reduced energy used
to cool the campus by eighty-six percent
combined heat and power plant if anybody
ever had a chance to tour that it's
essentially two 747 jet engines running
on natural gas they're producing
electricity and the heat to the exhaust
create steam it's all captured instead
of wasted solar power if you fly in our
naughty ithaca airport i'm sure you've
seen the solar array out there there's
now one at geneva i think the black oak
project the wind project is has the
green light I'm not absolutely sure but
Cornell is one of the few if not the
only universities in the world or the
u.s. that has a hydroelectric plant
produces all of one percent of our
electricity it used to produce all of it
LEED buildings anybody know what's wrong
with the gate building right there you
see those fins they're directly
connected by metal to the inside so
there's a transfer of heat out or cold
in and out ends you know this is one of
the things that changing with the new
codes don't bear with me don't let
Dean's and architect put up buildings
you need an energy person there as well
because they got to look pretty in that
you know etc energy conservation if you
play tennis they put new lights out
there saving a lot of money like twenty
thousand dollars per year in energy
costs and there's a about 50 buildings
on campus have the stash bored so I went
this morning and I checked on bradfield
probably not the best building to do
this and how much energy was used but so
far this week starting monday at 12am to
roughly a few minutes ago forty thousand
kilowatt hours of electricity for
bradfield
thirty six hundred dollars in costs and
thirty-six thousand six hundred pounds
of co2 operate that building for the
entire year is costs about three hundred
thousand dollars per year you can this
is pretty easy pretty handy you can go
in and type in any building it gets kind
of immediate feedback on energy use in a
building not on electricity but also
chilled water and heat this is a will
reflect the energy conservation these
are new buildings that were built over
the year the dark line is square foot it
square gross square feet you can see the
quite an increase on year 2000 to 2016
this is steam sales flat electrical
sales flat chilled water flat despite a
very large increase in our number of
buildings and square footage just
reflects the effort that the facilities
and sustainability office put into this
so the carbon neutrality by 2035
typically these are driven by financial
reasons this as a quadruple bottom line
does a solution help Cornell fulfill its
academic mission and purpose does it
meet the needs of the people on campus
and then communities will enhance
overall prosperity for the campus in our
region does it support a sustainable
planet it also includes natural gas and
the leakage issue solutions for tomorrow
the big one is Earth sword heat digging
down about two miles to tap the warmth
and deep rock and using that to in park
Heath the campus there's heat pumps
nuclear was actually considered or we
can just buy our way out of this through
offsets that's looking the longer term
this is a depiction of ulta called deep
rock geothermal going down ten to thirty
thousand feet this is not a trivial
investment very expensive and it we
initially experimental
more short-term what do we do build more
high performance buildings concern
energy switch over at much as pasta to
electrical vehicle increase our capacity
there's this thing called think big live
green which is really all of us
participating and doing what we can in
their offices and elaborate laboratories
there's also a campus climate huh not
campus campus whether see its climate
campus literacy I personally don't think
anybody should graduate from this
institution without being fully aware
climate change means to their life it's
a living laboratory and this climate
literacy is the why we're doing it and
there's two working groups that are
going to be formed one focused on
climate literacy how do we incorporate
more of that in two experiences for
students and our staff and faculty and
also a group coming together and how do
we really change behavior and when I say
group these are the faculty working with
staff the faculty have the expertise and
I have a personal issue with windows
open when it's a hundred degrees outside
this one's pretty close to home this is
Kennedy one day I walked up to Kennedy
and Roberts hall and there were 13
windows open and the ACS run him helen
newman i'm in the gym my hair is getting
messed up because the air conditioner is
blowing so hard the doors wide open some
of this stuff just simple behavior
changes could really make a difference I
just love to have a group of students
having the opportunity to wander on
campus and just start sort of grading
occupants these are really simple things
but in fact they're their game changers
is it possible for the faculty to work
with staff to make these kind of changes
this is Cal's green that happened in
2011 energy conservation and several
buildings the winner was barton lab in
Geneva but in one year we saved about
two hundred thousand two hundred thirty
thousand dollars in energy costs two
million pounds of co2 those are the
simple things as the experiment station
which I was director of weed
set of culture sustainability where
people were empowered to find better
ways of doing things that was actually a
sustainable action team one of the
things they did on their own was to
reduce the greenhouse footprint by
25,000 square feet saving a college 300
to 400 thousand dollars a year they also
designed a better growth chamber that
uses eighty-five percent less energy so
to Grand Challenge we can tackle us if
we have the will and look what we've
accomplished as a species art disease on
to the moon we have these things called
iPhones technology agriculture
engineering we can do remarkable things
but we have to decide we really want to
do it I challenge all of us get informed
stay informed accept the truth making it
personal helps leading is also a good
thing and raise your voices and it's
personal to alums from Cornell 06 and
Tim when they look back what I'm going
to say why didn't they take action thank
you it was on the solutions that huge
register
I come on
yes
kidding what what are the kind thoughts
about some of these solution would be
best what anyone is worse or see if yes
very expensive to halt etc but it's
essentially the energy from here it's
pretty and it just Billy I'm capturing
that heat inclusion bringing it up and
it's hot water would be steamed that hot
water then is instead of the curtains
havta starting with cold water giving
that up everybody got hot water going
they would also potentially change the
entire beings as one campus from steam
hot water there could be another
investment but that if it works we
replicated real gauging that's
longer-term like a great talk these are
great green on friday at all i think
most people realize how terrible that
building is force building the highest
energy costs on campus because of the
any need or air conditioning that comes
in goes directly out and so ymmv handled
but the comment i wanted to make is is
related to the buildings in general on
campuses as the problem is that when
buildings that operate or new buildings
constructed there isn't apparent need to
have probably and have the beautiful
buildings but in the cost of the older
buildings that that never get turned to
to be upgraded so you get this it's nice
to have all the lead buildings but if
you spend 120 million dollars in one day
with the means and other buildings like
graduate Emerson stay the same and
pretty awful working
well that's a problem state 17th healer
in countries like Germany can do RB
what's your stance on Taylor energy and
countries like Jerry given the threat of
climate change I from an epithet for an
employer however their calls for these
men reader reactors which are smaller
distributed energy production which we
need much better breaking moving that's
where Pink's handsome wrote his book
swarming my grandchildren and that's
essentially his therapist for unity
reinvest in newer technology and the
reader actors use existing nuclear waste
we're spring a nice one they don't have
to go Frankie and I think there are some
experimental welton part of the
experiment here is that I'm sure he'll
give you have to go if I understood one
of the countries that you showed
shows that this part of country
on the other hand the temperature is
also increase so what's the net effect
are we going to have more likelihood of
drought events or less
globally and get 30-fold increase in
rowlett events I understand it not that
much Peter but just more extremes lady
yes more precipitation higher
temperatures and increasing frequency of
rough eventual they're also increasing
le Marchant or Ariana both know what
that funds our comic spectroscopy or
pecan and I think top is really good I
think we need really need to focus on
adaptation and I think sometimes people
can get distracted by the co2 effect as
the new calculation show it doesn't take
much co2 to raise the temperature and
both of the new calculations coming up
during a town near boone spectroscopy
analysis so i think in the evening
keeping the carbon neutrality is very
important but it could be as low as this
is that could be seen as low as 50 parts
per million carbon dioxide so that means
it's that makes our really scary because
it's not going to take much just any
more increase in solar radiation
temperatures are going to keep going up
so I just like these don't get too
distracted by the co2 okay and don't so
we can focus on that DAP tation okay
okay if I yesterday okay want to thank
them give one tomorrow too and if
there's another side just because if you
also see we're also seeing more more
solder and contribute more to electric
or I mean I want to me they're told
after that comes out in actions reached
in principle a clean coal you highlight
that
yeah I'm sorry I be no I'm serious the
result is all right that's the ideas and
lower sulfur that's on the other
contaminants but not that door seal
fighters like that the contribution of
agriculture
we've got a whirl of tempers and
globally it's eighteen to twenty percent
like
I think it hardens agriculture because
the rice production was anybody don't
you know well that Bulger is a large
part of the gdp for a lot of those
countries we have also a lot of
industries that's probably just
right way another problem with those
statistics is there's a lot of embodied
energy and embodied greenhouse gas
emissions and what we import so actually
our footprint is much larger than it
appears if you just analyze the
emissions country by country it is
disproportionate ten percent of our gdp
I hopes not ten percent of our key to be
as much less it's like four percent so
I've district is it still
disproportionate
thank you for the presentation I thought
it felt really nice to move like you can
all do these small parts to decrease our
own energy usage but isn't it if you are
small part but again such an
insignificant card still and that we're
all operating in this very high energy
environment but we justify it because
you're working in things like better
climate change environment and we're all
working for it's unreadable but what is
Cornell University doing as an
institution of existence to magically
change this high energy oh well I try to
share as much as I go to what 1l is
doing
the operations do a lot more like
University of you know you're talking
dead at risk not proud but closets
Cornell talking to you there is a major
clear I'm not sleeves are all this
that's right it just happened to look at
that so the upper administration
positions across the country Provost be
machines by every second I think we have
trustees that don't believe in managing
I'm here I feel like when you think
about okay as the Southwest is going to
you know get drier and I coach is going
to be moved to another centralized
somewhere else I guess I fear that we
will just repeat the same issues with
centralized agriculture I mean maybe
we'll have new energy sources and things
like that but we'll still have this
great demand to move stuff around
fertilizer for you know all that stuff
like so it feels like to me is where I
guess a question are there as many
efforts going toward some kind I know
that it's happening at a grassroots
level to decentralize some of
Agriculture but I do have this fear that
will just move it somewhere else it
still have the distribution by
transportation costs all that's right
yeah yeah and you know energy yes let's
hope not I mean not just we're in the
process of trying to put together a USB
a proposal right now
the Northeast and preparing for climate
change and it has transportation
components that has a whole food chain
involved or try to get all the new room
good kind of layout scenarios or what
its gonna look like in the future and
how do we work together that's my answer
it's very complicated enormous amounts
of money a lot of food grown in the
wrong places and then you think that's
global shocks and what if California
agriculture does collapse there 2060
what does that mean globally words to
say here so I'm going to get food that
actually I would contract our contact at
a while back paisan it your energy
trying to find a group of a consulting
group that would come in and help them
understand what the food comes from
because of plunging that's kind of a
driver if you get metropolitan area
asking those questions then we can
change weeks seems to me like some some
worthwhile work to would just be on the
consumer level about this vehicle
locally not eating everything
one more what are you like we have a
three thousand foot boss operation so
we're trying to do it centrally opponent
wearing snow pants we come up and I
think we're selling out of all of our
tomatoes you know so local production
because you can make it fresh you can
have a taste good so it's still face out
of its flavored of all its nutrients and
if it's done locally and this way to
adapt to climate change in it does work
and market it at lower carbon all right
let's type on this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu